listen i don't want to make this about
me but you and i i feel like we got the
bright colors going on did we understand
the assignment i feel like we
telepathically knew what to do we did it
it's also feeling like miami out here
in toronto yeah i feel like the tent is
really sealing everything in it's all
the flavors and the smells and the heat
no it you look amazing thank you so
listen you're a marvel superhero right
we know harry styles has entered the mcu
as arrows yeah shawn mendes is here
tonight from one musician to another can
you get him in the mcu oh that's a
wonderful question i mean he's already
my superhero that's a good idea but but
he should be the world superhero as well
shall we put that in a sound bite and
send it out to the world sean mendes
should be a superhero yeah let's do it
kevin feige i hope you're listening
let's make some calls let's make some
calls we'll think this happens
he's an underwear model like he's you
know he's got he's got a good body he's
got he's ready he can handle it most
important question of the night how much
do you miss the blonde hair
um you know what i'm glad it happened
and i'm also glad to leave it behind i'm
really happy with what i got going on
right now amazing listen you don't need
to change a thing but i do want to know
how you reacted the first time you saw
margot robbie as barbie and ryan gosling
as ken like what was your reaction oh my
god it was it was crazy i mean i you
know saw the pictures and everything a
little bit before everybody else did um
but i remember
getting to the screen test a few days
before we were going to camera for the
first time and seeing them standing
together just being like oh wow yeah
it's going to be an incredible movie and
as an homage to that movie i must say a
little bit of barbie pink i don't know
i'm sorry how did i not pick up on this
right there there's layers to this
there's such good layers to this this is
so exciting who are you most excited to
see tonight because everyone's so pumped
that you're hosting the awards show i
think it's gotta be i think it's gotta
be avril right right she's she's having
a moment like a big resurgence and and
i'm here for it i mean
so much of my childhood was like rocking
out to skaterboy and complicated and
everything so no i'm so excited i'm
gonna fanboy super hard i love it you're
gonna kill it tonight i'm so happy to
meet you